ANITA KIBUNGUCHY-GRANT:
Hello, and welcome
to Google Cloud Next.
In this session,
we'll walk through how
to accelerate your move to the
cloud with managed databases.
If you're here to learn
about Cloud SQL, Bare Metal
Solution for Oracle, Database
Migration Service, and more,
then you are in the right place.
We'll also explore why Google
Cloud for your databases.
My name is Anita
Kbunguchy-Grant,
and I am the product
marketing lead here
for the Databases organization.
And I have the pleasure of being
joined by GG, group product
manager for databases.
So let's go ahead
and get started.
Here's a quick agenda
for this session.
We'll start with
what we're seeing
in the industry across trends,
go through five reasons
why Google Cloud
for your databases.
We'll hear from GG about
real-world customer use cases
and finally end with
how to get started,
including some important
resources you should check out.
So some migration trends.
Managed services just
makes sense for databases.
I have never met someone
who loved managing database
infrastructure, at
least just not yet.
When you think about
all the care and feeding
necessary to keep your
databases healthy,
there are a lot of
things to consider--
all the work to provision,
set up, and maintain
your hardware, the operating
system, and database software,
plus all the management
tools and [INAUDIBLE] patches
for security and maintenance;
scaling the system;
ensuring that your backups and
restores are meeting recovery
goals; and that the
application can continue
to run during various failure
recoveries and scenarios;
on top of all this,
monitoring all of these things
to make sure that
your system is running
the way your business needs to.
This is a lot of work
and pretty diverse set
of skills that are needed.
Consider the
thousands of databases
run by many companies.
This work really adds up.
Most importantly,
these are things
that are just table
stakes for you
and typically not
the things that
help you outmaneuver
your competitors.
It's therefore no
surprise that databases
are moving fast to the cloud.
According to Gartner,
75% of all databases
will be deployed or migrated
to a Cloud platform by 2022,
and this is massive.
It's important to note that the
Cloud DBMS market is not new,
but what is new is a growth
in cloud revenue, which
is actually projected to account
for 50% of the total DBMS
market revenue by 2023.
This trend actually helps
reinforce the notion
that cloud service provider
infrastructure and the services
that run on top of
them are becoming
the new data-management
platforms.
And because of
this, it's no wonder
that so many companies
are turning to managed
services in the cloud--
for their databases, that is.
So why not let someone
else who does it
for millions of
deployments and who's
been automating systems
like this for decades
handle this for you?
Let's talk about why Google
Cloud offers the best place
to migrate your databases.
We'll start with
reason number one.
We offer a
comprehensive platform
that allows you
to securely unify
the data across your
entire organization.
This allows you to break
down silos, increase agility,
innovate faster, and support
business transformation.
We connect the different
roles that work with data
and provide them a common
platform to build upon.
So no matter where
you start, there's
always more places to go across
analytics, databases, AI,
and machine-learning services.
BigQuery, our fully managed
enterprise data warehouse,
allows you to run analytics
at scale up to 34% lower TCO
than other cloud data
warehouse alternatives.
Spanner provides
unlimited scale,
global consistency across
regions, and high availability
up to five nines.
Looker provides a
single shared place
for people and
applications to interact
with it no matter the cloud.
And these are just a
few of the key services
you can take advantage of on
the Google Cloud data platform.
As I mentioned earlier,
no matter where you start,
there's always more places to
go with best-in-class products
across the entire
data lifecycle.
Let's take a look at
reason number two.
At Google Cloud, we
understand that most companies
have a multidatabase strategy.
In some cases, it's intentional.
In others, it's a natural
outcome of growth and change
over the years,
plus the fact that
replatforming a database
can be very intimidating.
So we've been steadily focused
on building options that
help meet you
where you are today
and also give you a
path for the future.
When you look at some of
the most popular databases,
there are great options
on Google Cloud.
These are for Oracle, SQL
Server, Postgres, and MySQL.
And for Postgres,
MySQL, and SQL Server,
the Database Migration
Service provides
a serverless experience for
quickly and safely migrating
your databases from
anywhere to Cloud SQL.
We also support nonrelational
database workloads.
If you're using
Redis, you can now
take advantage of Google Cloud
Memorystore for Redis or Redis
Labs, one of our key
database partners.
For Memcached, you can now
use Memorystore for Memcached.
For HBase and if you're ready
to move off your Hadoop stack,
you can easily
migrate to Bigtable,
which has been in production
for over 15 years at Google
and is the original
inspiration for HBase.
For all that MongoDB
you're self-managing,
you can use MongoDB
Atlas on Google Cloud.
All of these provide
options and flexibility
to quickly and safely migrate
to the cloud, helping meet you
where you are.
Let's take a look at
reason number three.
We've talked about some of
the product capabilities.
Let's do a deeper dive
into some of them.
Let's start with Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL is our fully managed
relational database service
and one of Google Cloud's
fastest-growing top services.
Over the past year,
the team has been
focused on addressing
many of the major blockers
for customers, and we now
have unique capabilities
in the market.
We added the Database
Migration Service
to migrate your MySQL,
Postgres, and SQL Server
workloads to Cloud SQL.
We've significantly
reduced maintenance windows
by over 80%, and we've also
launched Cloud SQL Insights,
which bring database
observability
to your developers.
We were first to market to
support the latest versions,
including Postgres
13, because we
want to make sure this
is the simplest migration
experience for you.
Cloud SQL also
offers integration
with Kubernetes, which makes
connecting your applications
easy and secure.
It also supports
federation with BigQuery,
and we've seen users carrying
over 125 petabytes of data
in Cloud SQL, on
average, in one month.
And so Cloud SQL is pretty
ready for you critical
relational workloads on MySQL,
Postgres, and SQL Server.
The next service we'll
do a deeper dive on
is the Bare Metal
Solution for Oracle.
We've taken an optimized
approach with our BMS solution
for Oracle.
We provide certified
and optimized hardware
for your Oracle
workloads, allowing
you to run all versions of
Oracle database, including RAC,
and all the tools and
playbooks you use today,
such as Data Guard and RMAN.
You get to maintain your
on-premises licensing, run
books, DBAs, and
system integrators.
Google provides management
of the data center
with enterprise-grade
security and reliability.
We're available in
13 cloud regions,
and we're less than
2 milliseconds away
from Google Cloud resources.
With Bare Metal
Solution for Oracle,
you have full control
over how the data is
managed using optimized
and certified SAN storage.
And finally, we'll take a
look at some of the tools
and partners available.
As I mentioned earlier, we
announced Database Migration
Service to migrate your MySQL,
Postgres, and SQL Server
workloads onto Cloud SQL, and
we're seeing a lot of customers
start to use Database
Migration Service to migrate
their workloads.
We also hear that DMS is easy
to use, and more than 85%
of the migrations using DMS are
underway in less than one hour.
We also announced Datastream
earlier this year,
a CDC and change data capture
service that provides access
to streaming low-latency data
from Oracle and MySQL databases
with integrations across
BigQuery, Cloud Spanner,
Dataflow and Data Fusion.
We also work with partner
solutions like Stream
and also offer assessment
tools, including StratoZone
and migVisor to get you quickly
started on your migration
journey.
Reason number four for
why Google Cloud is we
provide robust
tools and technology
to protect and govern your
data throughout its lifecycle.
We realize that security
and governance are
key concerns for many
of our customers,
and providing these
controls are key to peace
of mind for your databases.
We offer built-in data
protection at scale,
and this is by
default. All your data
is automatically encrypted
while in transit and at rest.
We've also added
customer-managed encryption
keys for some of
our key services,
including Cloud SQL and Spanner.
Secondly, we supply
tools and technology
to efficiently govern your data.
Cloud Identity and
Access Management
provides access
control and visibility
into security policies
across your organization.
Thirdly, we support
compliance requirements
with third-party audits
and certifications.
And finally, we
believe that trust
is created through
transparency, and so we provide
tools such as Access
Transparency which give you
visibility into accesses by
either support or engineering.
And all these
capabilities ensure
that your data is protected.
And finally, let's look
at reason number five
for why Google Cloud.
It goes without saying
that your databases are
as good as your availability.
We offer five nines
industry-leading
SLA across our cloud-native
databases, Spanner, Firestore,
and Bigtable, and four
nines SLA for BigQuery.
And these databases
are actually built
on Google's dedicated
network, and they're
battle tested by Google
Cloud Services used
by billions of users,
and they're actually
made available for your use.
All these services are simply
unmatched for speed, scale,
security, and capability
for any sized organization,
and these availability
SLAs ensure
that your business continues
to run without disruption.
So there you have
it, five key reasons
why migrating your
databases to Google Cloud
is a good move
for your business,
from the fact that
we offer managed
services for your Oracle,
MySQL, Postgres, and SQL Server
workloads, including
Redis, MongoDB, and HBase,
to the sophisticated security
and privacy controls,
all the way to the five nines
availability across some
of our key services.
Whew.
I realize that was a
ton of information,
so it would be good
to be able to bring
all these things to life.
So let's do a deep dive
into three key customer use
cases across some of
these key services.
So I'm excited to welcome
GG, group product manager
to talk more to us.
Welcome, GG.
GURMEET GOINDI:
Thank you, Anita.
Indeed, that is a great
overview of our portfolio
and the reasons why customers
are choosing our solutions.
And I 100% agree with you.
In my 20 years of my career
here in Silicon Valley,
I have not met a single person
who wakes up in the morning
and said managing databases
really excites me.
What they do wake
up and tell us is
how we can help them run these
databases more efficiently,
more reliably, help them build
new customer experiences,
at the same time
lowering their cost.
One such customer that
I like to talk about
is a leading travel service
provider or travel company,
you might say.
This industry is
in a lot of churn,
and customers are trying
to-- these companies
are trying to build
new experiences
for their customers, and the
customer base is also evolving.
So this company turned
to us, and the reason
they like the strategy is
the breadth of our product
portfolio, whether it be the
world's leading five nines
databases such as
Spanner or our ability
to provide a stable,
secure, high-performing home
for their legacy databases at
states which might be running
on databases like Oracle.
This particular
customer had a lot
of Oracle databases running on
premises, on AWS, you name it.
The permanent solution, we
were able to provide them
a home where they can
migrate as is and then
upgrade these
databases to Spanner
or other cloud-native
databases at their own pace.
Not only they were able to
keep all of their run books
and playbooks and partners
as is, at the same time
they were able to benefit
from the extreme low latency
to Google Cloud so that they
can iterate their workloads back
and forth between a
cloud-native database
and a traditional
database such as Oracle.
What was a little
needle mover for them,
they had [INAUDIBLE]
of Oracle versions,
and they probably used every
possible Oracle HA technology.
With Oracle BMS, they've
been able to leverage
those technologies
as is and move
the databases to production
in a record amount of time.
On the other
spectrum of industry,
I would like to share an
example with a leading
German bank we are working on.
All of you might know banks are
really particular about data
security-- not that
others are not,
but they're regulated towards
data security, data residency,
and privacy.
With the Oracle
Bare Metal Solution,
they were able to meet
their stringent regulatory
requirements placed
upon them as a business.
At the same time, with the
help of our engineering teams,
they were able to migrate over a
hundred mission-critical Oracle
databases to Oracle Bare Metal
Solution within three months.
Now they're using
the data sitting
in the databases in
Bare Metal Solution
to bring new
experiences by using
cloud-native databases in GCP.
Last but not the least, I
would like to talk about one
of my favorite use cases is
this big ticketing marketplace
which built the entire business
on a set of clustered databases
running on Oracle.
And they looked to GCP to help
them take this marketplace
and transform it in
an extensible scale
that Spanner provides--
extensible and five-nine
availability that
Spanner provides.
But this journey is
not simple and needs
a lot of steps and
iteration between them.
So they decided to move their
clustered databases, which
is running on aging hardware,
to the state of the art
infrastructure provided by
Oracle Bare Metal Solution that
enabled them to not only
modernize or at least lower
the cost of running
the databases using
modern hardware on
Oracle Bare Metal
Solution-- at the
same time, start
modernizing their existing
applications with Google Cloud
Spanner.
Last but not least,
this customer
has been live with running one
of the largest Oracle clusters
in any public cloud of
Bare Metal Solution,
and we are very happy
to have them here.
With that being said, Anita,
I'll hand it back to you
to take us to this presentation.
Thank you for your time.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY-GRANT:
Thank you so much, GG.
Those are all such
great example use cases,
and I'm sure many of that will
actually resonate with you.
So how should you think
about moving forward
with your migration journey?
A good migration plan is
going to have four key phases.
First, your
assessment phase where
you work to understand
exactly what you have already.
Secondly, based on
that assessment,
you start to plan
what you should move
and how you should move it.
Third, you start to execute
the migration itself.
And finally, you fine tune and
optimize what you've migrated.
I think this should
sound pretty familiar.
GG just talked about the
customer who actually
went through these type
of four key phases,
and they're actually still
going through that journey.
And I realized that we're
representing this migration
plan as a single circle,
but in reality, it's
a bit more recursive
in that you'll
have your high-level
migration plan,
but then you also have
groups of applications called
migration waves that have their
own specific plans as well,
and each subsequent
plan in theory
is adapting the lessons from
previous migration waves.
In addition, it's not
uncommon to go back and forth
between each of the
four different phases.
It's all about building
that migration muscle memory
and realizing that
this is a journey.
And so what tools do we offer?
And all of these should now
sound very, very familiar.
For your database
assessments, you
should check up
migVisor and StratoZone.
We have 50-plus
regional champions
trained on migVisor that are
a combination of CEs, PSO,
and partner
engineering teams who
are ready to help you
carry out your assessments.
We also offer partner
programs as well.
We also talked about the
Database Migration Service
for your MySQL, Postgres,
and SQL Server workloads.
And finally, we're also
working really hard
to improve that customer
experience across our teams
and services to help you quickly
and safely and efficiently
migrate your databases
to Google Cloud.
And last but not least,
make sure you check out
this great white-paper resource
with a lot of good information
around migrating your databases.
It has a lot of the
content we spoke about
in this presentation
and actually provides it
in much more detail.
It will be included
in the Resource
section of this presentation.
You can also get started with
some hands-on labs as well.
I know that Cloud SQL
is widely represented,
and so you can actually
get started on checking out
the hands-on labs there.
And so I'd like
to thank you again
for joining us for
this presentation
and for this session, and we
absolutely value your feedback,
so please take the
time to provide it.
Let us know what we did
well and what we could have
done to improve for next time.
Thank you so much,
and thanks again,
GG, for joining me this session.
GURMEET GOINDI: Thanks,
Anita, for having me.